>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sue Siegel: Good afternoon.
I'm Sue Siegel.
I'm the Director of Development
at the Library of Congress.
And this is a great
day for the Library.
One we look forward
to the entire year.
We get to recognize and
celebrate the importance
of reading and authors and books.
Now we like to think that we make
it seem easy to do this every year.
But the truth is that the National
Book Festival is a huge undertaking.
It's a huge financial undertaking.
And it's been made possible
by generous support
from our many sponsors.
You can see who they are in your
programs, and on the video monitors
around the Convention Center.
But we really can't take for granted
that this event will
continue to exist.
So I would ask you to consider
making a contribution right now
using your cell phone.
You can send a text to make a
one-time gift that will be added
to your mobile phone bill.
And the details should
be on the screen
and on the back of your program.
And now on to the main event.
It's my privilege to introduce one
of America's most generous
supporters
of the arts, history and culture.
A tireless champion of
reading and literacy.
And a man without whom there would
not be a National Book Festival.
Our lead benefactor and
Co-Chairman, David Rubenstein.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So thank you.
So how many people
here have never been
to the National Book
Festival before?
Anybody? Oh, okay.
How many people been five times?
Ten times?
Okay. And how many people
like the price of admission?
Okay. Okay.
So we're very privileged
today to have one
of America's leading
scholars, certainly in the area
of national security and
defense, Graham Allison.
And let me introduce Graham.
And we're going to talk
about his latest book,
which I highly recommend.
I have finished reading
it not long ago.
And we'll go through the book today.
Graham is a graduate of
Harvard College, class of '62.
He won a Marshall Scholarship.
And got a degree at Oxford,
came back to Harvard,
and got his Ph.D. at Harvard.
And started teaching
at Harvard in 1968.
So he's now been a
member of the faculty
at Harvard for about 50 years.
During that period of time he
was essentially the founding dean
of the Harvard Kennedy School,
and did that job for 12 years.
Subsequent to that he became
the head of the Belfer Center
for Science and International
Policy at Harvard,
and did that for 21 years,
now succeeded by Ash Carter,
former Secretary of Defense.
In addition to those
administrative roles,
Graham has been a leading
scholar on a number
of areas related to
national security.
One of them is the
Cuban Missile Crisis,
where he's written
probably the definitive book
on the Cuban Missile Crisis.
And he's written another book,
which is now I think will be the
definitive book on our relationships
between China and the United States.
And that's called "Destined
for War: Can America
and China Escape Thucydides's Trap?"
Okay? You've got our attention.
What is Thucydides's trap?
>> Graham Allison: Okay.
So Thucydides's trap is the
dangerous dynamic that occurs
when a rising power threatens
to displace a ruling power.
Thucydides wrote about the rise
of Athens in classical Greece.
But you can think about the rise
of Germany the decades
right before World War I,
or the rise of China today.
And when a rising power threatens
to displace a ruling power,
we should expect poop happens.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So for those who are not experts in
ancient Greek, who was Thucydides?
>> Graham Allison: Well,
that's a great question.
And Thucydides should be
part of the mental library
of every educated person.
I've been two months promoting
this book since it was published.
And I've learned that,
first, Americans don't
like multi-syllabic words.
And, secondly, that
Thucydides is a mouthful.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
What's the most [inaudible]--
>> Graham Allison: Let me just
make sure we've got it in unison.
One, two, three.
Thucydides.
>> David M. Rubenstein: What is
the most interesting pronunciation
you've heard?
>> Graham Allison: Well, if you
watch, we put up in conjunction
with the book a website, a
Thucydides's Trap website.
And you can Xi Jinping,
the President of China,
trying to say,"Th, th, th, th, th,"
because Chinese don't
pronounce Thucydides as--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: The way
that I mush up Mandarin words.
But, any case, Thucydides
was the founder of history.
He wrote the first
ever history book.
So you can go download for free "The
History of the Peloponnesian War,"
and read the first 100 pages.
And if every page doesn't
make your heart go pitter-pat,
check your pulse.
>> David M. Rubenstein: All right.
Well, let's talk about this.
So what he did is he wrote a
book on the Peloponnesian War,
which was a war between Sparta,
which was the dominant power
in the Peloponnesians, and then
Athens, which was the rising power.
So under Thucydides's
trap, the trap being
that the rising power ultimately
might get the feeling it should
attack the larger power,
the more traditional power,
who attacked there?
Did Athens attack Sparta?
Is that what happened?
>> Graham Allison: Well,
that's a great question,
because Thucydides's main idea
was that you have this dynamic.
I'm the ruling power.
You're the rising power.
The rising power is
thinking, "I'm bigger.
I'm stronger.
I deserve more say.
I deserve more sway.
The current arrangements don't
take account of my interests."
And the ruling power thinks,
"This other [inaudible] is trying
to upset the status quo that's
provided the environment that's been
good for everybody,
especially for you.
How did you grow up?"
So in that environment,
in some cases in the cases
that I've studied, a
rising power decides, "Well,
I'll fight the ruling
power," or the ruling power,
"I'll fight the rising power."
But that's not Thucydides's story.
Thucydides's story is that in
this dynamic both protagonists are
vulnerable to the action
of third parties.
So in Thucydides's story
you've got a rise of Athens,
the fear in Sparta, and then
Corinth, which is an ally of Sparta,
gets into a tangle with Corcyra.
And they drag Athens and Sparta
into a war neither of them wanted.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
But in the end Athens
attacked Sparta?
>> Graham Allison: Well,
again, it becomes complicated.
They get dragged in.
The Spartans began
violating the terms,--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: The
Athenians vote for war.
And then there's about six months
in which the war doesn't
actually happen,
where they could have
resolved the war even then.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
All right.
So at Harvard, the Kennedy School,
you started something called
"Thucydides's Trap
Project," which said, "Okay.
If Athens and Sparta had this
problem, and they went to war,
let's see how many cases
in the ensuing 2,000 years
or so there were similar situations
where a rising power got trapped
into attacking a more
dominant power."
So how many instances were there?
>> Graham Allison: Well, so we've
only looked at the last 500 years.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: So just
the most recent 500 years,
starting with the end
of the 15th century--
>> David M. Rubenstein: All right.
>> Graham Allison:
Up until currently.
We found 16 cases, 1, 6, in
which a rising power threatens
to displace a ruling power.
Twelve of them ended in war.
Four of them in not war.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So to avoid the Thucydides's
trap, you have to figure
out what the four did that avoided
the war, and what the twelve did
that didn't avoid the war.
Okay. So let's go through
some examples through history.
So let's take an example
where a war was not avoided.
A rising power in the west was Japan
in the late 1930s and early 1940s.
The United States is the dominant
power in the Pacific to some extent.
So how did that come about?
Did Japan feel the United States
didn't take them seriously enough?
The United States didn't
know how to treat Japan?
What happened there?
>> Graham Allison: Well,
it's a great question.
And it's a long story.
But I'll just try to do
the capsule in the book.
In the appendix I give a little
capsule histories of each of these.
So basically about the turn of the
century, maybe just the beginning,
Japan starts rising and
getting bigger and stronger.
All of Asia has been
colonized by everybody else.
The U.S. establishes something
called an open-door policy
in which it says everything's
going to stay the way things are.
But the Japanese are feeling their
cut out of guaranteed resources
as their economy gets
bigger and stronger.
So they begin to be more aggressive.
They act against China.
They are aggressive
against Indonesia.
The U.S. says to them,
"Absolutely not.
Stop." But first we do
a trade war with them.
Then we do an embargo
on their shipments.
Then we do an oil embargo.
And not realizing and
not understanding
that from the Japanese
point of view this looked
like we were simply strangling them.
And we were to the point of where
in the Japanese calculation
they could either be strangled
by the U.S. immediately,
or they could take a chance
on attacking the U.S. at
Pearl Harbor, as they did.
And, so, they chose to attack.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So that's what happened there.
The Thucydides's trap
could not be avoided.
Let's take another example.
In the early part of the
20th century in Europe,
Germany was a rising power.
And while we know Germany
is a powerful country then,
it was really coming
together as a country,
because it was being put together,
the dominant power was England.
So how did Germany look at England?
And how did they not avoid that
the Thucydides's trap there?
>> Graham Allison: Well, again,
I have a chapter on
"The Road to 1914."
And I would say this is the
most eerie in similarity
to what we're seeing
in the rise of China.
So Germany got unified as
a country in the 1870s.
They then began to grow.
They were about half the
size of the GDP of Britain
at the time they unified.
By 1900 they were equal.
By 1914 they were recorded larger.
So they were on a tear.
From the point of view of Britain,
which had been the ruling power
for 100 years, this is the time
when it was said the sun never
set on the British Empire.
So they had Canada and
India and South Africa.
They had the Navy that
ruled the waves completely.
So the idea that here's this
Germany, which is now unified,
that's building up its strength,
building up its military strength,
building up its Navy, impacted
Britain so severely that they began
to become entangled
with third parties.
So Britain became entangled
with France.
France had an alliance with Russia.
This created a set of
interlocking commitments such that
when a third-party action,
which was completely bizarre,
[inaudible] the Archduke, who
was the successor to the throne
in Vienna, was assassinated in
Sarajevo by a Serbian terrorist.
So it would have been an
inconsequential event normally.
But that end up to serve as
a trigger to a set of actions
and reactions, by the end of
which all the parties were at war.
>> David M. Rubenstein: All right.
So in the case of World
War II and World War I,
the Thucydides's trap
was not avoided.
Let's take a case where
it was avoided.
In the lifetime of many people
here it was thought, by some of us,
that maybe the United States
and the then Soviet Union
could not avoid war.
We were the two dominant
post-World War II powers.
But we actually ended the
Cold War without any Hot War.
How did we actually
avoid the Hot War?
>> Graham Allison: Well, again, this
is one of the most amazing stories.
And I think Americans, especially
most of us lived through portions
of it, haven't really appreciated.
So first off, in the period right
after World War II, as you said,
we're left standing basically, the
U.S. in particular, with about half
of the world's GDP, and the Soviet
Union, which had actually done a lot
of the heavy lifting, in
the defeat of the Nazis.
So then things stumble
around for a while.
But by the 1950s, or by 1961
when John Kennedy comes to town
as president, the well-known fact
is that the Soviet Union is surging,
and is actually going to
overtake the U.S. in terms of GDP.
I show in the book a quote
from the economic textbook
of the time, Paul Sanderson,--
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Paul Sanderson.
>> Graham Allison: He predicts
that by the end of the '70s,
this is in his 1964 textbook, the
Soviet Union will overtake the U.S.
So the fear in terms of the
impact of the Soviet Union,
the missile gap, all the
things that surrounded that,
in that context the people we
celebrate still as the wise men,
people like George Kennan, who
wrote back the famous telegram,
or Acheson, or Vandenberg,
the Republican leader
of the Foreign Relations
Committee, or Truman in particular,
or Marshall, created
in a great surge
of imagination a strategy they
called "The Cold War Strategy."
And Cold War was competition
on every dimension,
and by all means except one--
no bombs and bullets
killing each other directly.
So you had this extreme
competition in every dimension--
economic, political, ideological,
covert action, even proxy wars,
but not you and me
killing each other.
And that came to some
very close calls,
as you and I've talked often before.
The Cuban Missile Crisis was
about, as Kennedy thought,
about a one in three chance that
would have ended in a nuclear war.
Well, it didn't.
They began to develop some
constraints on the competition.
And lo and behold it ended with
a whimper, rather than a bang.
>> David M. Rubenstein: All right.
So the Cold War ended.
And we didn't really
have a Hot War there.
So the Thucydides's trap
was avoided in that case.
>> Graham Allison: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Let's
go forward to China now.
Let's talk about China
and put it in context.
For most of organized history
China was the biggest economy
in the world.
Is that right?
>> Graham Allison: Mainly because
it just had the most people.
So everybody was poor, but
there was more of them in China,
so it was the largest
national economy.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
And then around the 1700s
or so Europe came along,
and Europe became a
more dominant economy.
And then China went--
>> Graham Allison:
And the Industrial
Revolution and technology.
And all of a sudden a
spurt in growth there.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
But China, therefore,
goes into relative oblivion
compared to where they had been.
In the 14 or 1500s maybe they
were the dominant economy
in the world, or at
least the largest.
Europe comes along.
And then ultimately China
has its revolutions.
And then in 1949 Mao Zedong
defeats Chiang Kai-shek.
And China goes kind of dark in
terms of the rest of the world.
Richard Nixon goes to China in 1972.
At that time what was the
size of the Chinese economy?
>> Graham Allison: Five
percent of the U.S. then.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Five percent.
Okay. And as a result of
Richard Nixon going to China,
and as a result of some leadership
changes, Deng Xiaoping came
in ultimately after Mao Zedong,
China decides to open
up to the west.
So over the last, let's say, 30, 40
years or so, China has been opening
up and growing its economy.
Where does China's economy stand
today relative to the United States?
>> Graham Allison: Well, again,
in Washington most
people won't know this,
as most Americans don't know this.
But China's economy today is
larger than the economy of the U.S.
That was the big takeaway from the
2014 IMF World Bank meeting here
in Washington.
And if you go to the CIA's website,
or you go to the IMF website,
and measure economies like what
those [inaudible] each of them,
both agree is the single
best measure,--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison: Which
is purchasing power parity,
China's economy is now about
10% larger than the U.S.
So I illustrate this in
the book with a seesaw.
So if you imagine a seesaw
on a kids' playground,
with the U.S. sitting on one end
and China sitting on the other.
In 1980, when Reagan became
president, China was 10% of the U.S.
By 2014 equal to the U.S. And
on the current trajectories
by 2024 will be 40% larger.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Now, for
those who may not be economists,
we measure in the United
States typically our economy
by something called "GDP,
Gross Domestic Product."
It used to be called
"GNP," but now GDP.
However, there's another measure
called "Purchase Price Parity," PPP,
and that really means the value
of the goods and services produced
in terms of the context
of the economy,
and what you can buy for it.
And by that measure, not by GDP,
but by Purchase Price
Parity, China is bigger today.
>> Graham Allison: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
But even by GDP China is not that
much smaller than the United States.
>> Graham Allison: Correct.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Is that correct?
>> Graham Allison: Correct.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
What about the military of China?
The United States has the largest
military budget in the world,
roughly 600 plus billion
dollars or so.
We spend the largest percentage
of our GDP on military probably
than any other country, or
at least the largest amount.
Where does China stand?
>> Graham Allison: Well, the
U.S. has invested in military
at multiples of China
for now decades.
So the U.S. stays substantially
ahead for the time being.
But China's growth
has been double-digit
for now almost 15 years.
And, so, in the regional
competition--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison: If you look at
the balance of power, for example,
in the East China Sea
or the South China Sea
or in the Korean Peninsula,
China has become stronger
and stronger relative to the U.S.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
Now does China have nuclear power?
>> Graham Allison: Yes.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
They have nuclear weapons.
>> Graham Allison: The Chinese
not only have nuclear weapons,
but they have what would be called
"a superpower nuclear arsenal."
That is they have so
many nuclear weapons,
and so reliable nuclear weapons,
that even if the U.S. attacked them,
we can't disarm them such that they
wouldn't be able to destroy us.
So they have the mutual assured
destruction condition that we ended
up with the Soviet Union, or we
continue to have with Russia today.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
Now does China say, "Well, United
States, you're a great country.
You have a nice democracy.
We admire your Jeffersonian
principles.
Therefore, we don't really want
to challenge you politically,
militarily or economically."
Do the Chinese leadership
say that or?
>> Graham Allison: Well, not quite.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: In the
book I quote Lee Kuan Yew,
who was the founder of Singapore
and the guy that built Singapore.
And he was also the world's
premier China watcher,
until he died in 2015.
So I put to him the question,
"Are the Chinese current leaders,
including Si, serious
about displacing the U.S.
as the predominant power in
Asia in the foreseeable future?"
Now if you ask any China expert that
they'll say, "Oh, it's complicated
on the one hand, on
the other hand-- ."
They won't really give
you an answer.
Lee Kuan Yew answers,
"Yes, of course.
Who could imagine otherwise?
How could they not aspire
to be number one in Asia,
and maybe in time in the world?"
So China's aspiration is that
it'll become the predominant power
in its neighborhood.
And its neighborhood is
everything it can see.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So the current leader, as
you mentioned, of China,
and the title is President,
as well as I guess the leader
of the Communist Party,
is Xi Jinping.
>> Graham Allison: Yes.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Is Xi Jinping different
than his predecessor, Hu Jintao,
or Jiang Zemin, his predecessor,
or is he roughly in the same mold?
>> Graham Allison: A
very different mold.
I would say Xi Jinping is
the most impressive leader
on the international stage today.
Extremely.
He, first, has taken over what
was a collective leadership,
and what the whole system,
the whole political system,
had tried to establish as
a collective leadership,
because they feared
one-man leadership,
because they remembered
Mao and the craziness
of the Cultural Revolution.
In two years he had basically
overturned that regime.
So now he's often referred to as
the COE, the Chief of Everything.
So he's in--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison:
Charge of the whole thing.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Now--
>> Graham Allison: And next month,
in October or the month after next,
he's going to have a party Congress,
at which they're going to anoint him
for another five years as president.
But probably in such
a way that it looks
like he could stay even longer.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Now for
those who don't follow this,
the Chinese have been
governed over the recent years
by a politburo of nine people.
But now he's reduced it to seven.
>> Graham Allison: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein: But, more to
the point, there's been a tradition,
it just says the United States,
you can get to elect a president
twice, serve eight years.
In China the tradition has
been you can be president two
five-year terms.
>> Graham Allison: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And
what you're saying is you think
that Xi Jinping might say, "After
my second five-year term I might
like a third or fourth
five-year term."
>> Graham Allison: I may need
to stay longer, because I've got
such an ambitious agenda.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: And
what is his agenda?
Long before Donald Trump had "Make
America great again," Xi Jinping,
in 2012 when he became president,
colloquially his line was
"Make China great again."
It's called the great rejuvenation
of the great Chinese people.
And in the Chinese view we were
great until westerners showed up.
Just what you were saying.
They showed up a couple hundred
years ago and exploited us.
And they engaged in imperialism, and
fought a war called "The Opium War"
in order to make legal we
could sell opium to them.
Okay? So that period
is over for Xi Jinping.
We're now big and strong enough.
Butt out [inaudible].
>> David M. Rubenstein: So, let's
see, in terms of the population,
the United States' population
is roughly 330 million?
>> Graham Allison: Yep.
>> David M. Rubenstein: The
population of China is what?
>> Graham Allison: 1.4.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Now that's 1.4,
though they had a one-child
policy for a long time.
Now they have essentially
abandoned the one-child policy.
Do you think that China's population
will grow exponentially now or not?
>> Graham Allison:
Not exponentially.
But it'll start creeping up, yes.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
Who is the biggest producer of
semi-conductors in the world?
>> Graham Allison: China.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Who's
the biggest producer of steel?
>> Graham Allison: China.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Biggest producer of cell phones?
>> Graham Allison: China.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Biggest
producer of television sets?
>> Graham Allison: China.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Who's
the biggest producer of,
I don't know, athletic equipment?
China.
>> Graham Allison: Everything.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Everything.
Okay. So in China--
>> Graham Allison: Who has
the biggest middle class?
China. Who has the
most billionaires?
fastest supercomputer?
China.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So having all these things,
does China say, "Well,
we're happy to be a little bit
subordinate to the United States
on the world scene, because the
United States you put the World Bank
together, you put the IMF
together, you put the UN together.
You deserve a lot of credit
for all those things you
did after World War II.
So we wouldn't mind being a little
subordinate to the United States."
So does Chinese leadership
say that now?
>> Graham Allison:
Well, again, not quite.
I should say initially their
ambition is in their region.
So they would like to be the
predominant power in Western Asia.
When they look out and see the
American Navy as the arbiter
in the South China Sea,
they think that's anomalous.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: I even
have a section in the book
that goes, "China sees China seas."
So basically a PLA Navy guy said
to me, "Look at your own map.
What is the name of
this body of water?
It's called the South China Sea.
It's not called the U.S. Sea.
Why then is the U.S. Navy
the dominant power there?"
And I say, "Wait a minute.
There was the Battle of Midway.
For seventy years we created
an economic and political order
and security order that's
been fantastic for you.
You should be grateful for that."
And they would say, "Well, okay, we
can accept that you did something.
But that's enough now.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison: We'll
take care of that."
>> David M. Rubenstein:
But you pointed
out in your book very tellingly
that the United States has a mindset
of kind of instant gratification.
We like things pretty quickly.
And for us a long-time horizon
might be a year or two or three.
The Chinese have a horizon
of, let's say, millennium.
I mean they will look at
100 years or even more.
>> Graham Allison: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So if China
has this long-term view why don't
they just not, why do we
have to worry about them,
because in a long-term they might
think they'll prevail, then, well,
the United States might fade.
So why do we have to worry about
any military confrontation,
because the Chinese
can just wait us out?
Is that not right?
>> Graham Allison: I think
that's a good question.
And I'm sure they think
a lot about that.
And I think that, in terms
of your previous question
about global leadership,
I don't think the Chinese
have much aspiration
for global leadership at the moment.
They're interested
in their regional,
they're just [inaudible]
first the well-being of China,
and second their neighborhood.
But in their neighborhood they find
the U.S. has the predominant power.
So the U.S. is the dominant
power in the South China Sea.
The U.S. is the dominant
power in the East China Sea.
The U.S. does have a military ally
in South Korea right
on their border.
The U.S. has a military ally
in Japan right around them.
So it's those pieces that
they'll push up against first.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So in the Obama administration there
was talk about a pivot to Asia,
implying that we were not going
to focus on Europe so much,
maybe not the Middle East so much,
we're going to pivot to Asia.
Were the Chinese happy that we're
paying more attention to them now,
or to Asia, or they weren't?
>> Graham Allison: No.
Between malign the tension
they preferred benign neglect.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So they weren't happy about that.
>> Graham Allison: They
were not too happy.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So in your book you point out
there are four potential areas
of confrontation between
the United States and China.
There could be more.
But you site four.
Let's just go through those four.
One is North Korea.
We have this conflict and it's
been going on for a long time
with South Korea and North Korea.
Your view is so possibly
something happened in North Korea
that might put a confrontation
between us and China.
Could you explain that?
>> Graham Allison: Again, it's
almost impossible to believe,
but I think if you look at the
facts North Korea, Kim Jong-un,
could drag China and the U.S. into
a war that nobody in China wants,
and nobody in the U.S. wants.
I was in Beijing just a month ago
talking about Thucydides's trap
with a group of PLA Colonels.
And a young man said, "You
know, no, it's impossible
that North Korea could
drag us into a war."
And I said, "Well, does
anybody think has this ever
happened before?"
And one of his colleagues
said, "Wait a minute.
What happened in 1950?"
In 1950 North Korea
attacked South Korea.
South Korea almost
captured the whole country.
The U.S. came to the
rescue at the last-minute,
pushed North Koreans back up the
peninsula, across the 38th parallel,
where the war started, towards the
Chinese border, the Yalu River.
Out of the blue came the
Chinese into the war.
This is only one year, as you said.
Only 49, Mao had just
barely won the Civil War.
Just one year after that their
economy's about a 50th their size.
So it hardly matters.
They attacked us and
beat us right back
down the peninsula
to the 38th parallel.
In that war 50,000 Americans died,
several hundred thousand
Chinese died,
and even millions of
South Koreans died.
That was not a war Mao wanted.
It was not a war the U.S. wanted.
But one thing happened
that knocked on the other
that knocked on the other.
So that's the Thucydidian idea--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: That
the two parties don't need
to want war for war to want them.
>> David M. Rubenstein: All right.
So let's, North Korea, let's
suppose that's a potential problem.
Let's talk about a second
one, the South China Sea.
The Chinese have built islands.
Maybe you can explain what
those islands are about,
and why that's a potential problem,
and a source of confrontation
between China and the United States.
>> Graham Allison: Well,
again, the Chinese ask,
"Why are the Americans trying
to decide whether we can build
an island or not if we want
to in our equivalent of the
Caribbean, or who owns this island,
and who owns that island?
Why does that matter to you?"
they ask me.
And I say, "Well, let me tell you
about the history of how we came
to be there, and the role we played
in providing the security
order in the region."
So China has claimed a number
of the islands and shoals
in the South China Sea that are also
claimed either by the Philippines
or by Vietnam or by
Indonesia or by others.
And it's built some islands
where there's a little
bit of a shoal underwater.
It builds an island around
them, about 5,000 square miles
of islands, so a lot of islands.
And on those islands they then
locate naval bases and air strips,
so that they can increase
their security,
or the role of their military forces
in the region, since they would
like to be, they imagine
they should be,
the dominant power in
the South China Sea.
Now, in fact, what they're trying
to do was push the U.S. back,
the U.S. Navy back behind the
so-called first island chain,
which is the chain that goes from
Japan around to the Philippines.
And now actually, if you look at
it, the U.S. Navy in situations
that risk conflict actually pulls
our carriers back beyond the first
island chain, because we don't
want them to be in arm's length.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
All right.
A third possible source
of confrontation,
you point out in your
book, is Taiwan.
Now what is the story on Taiwan?
Who really controls Taiwan?
And why are the Chinese so upset
about the United States
sort of support for Taiwan?
>> Graham Allison:
Well, one of the places
where Donald Trump almost
stumbled into a big mistake was
at the transition, when he basically
said, "Well, if Taiwan wants
to be a country, a free country,
why shouldn't it be a country?"
And if the president of Taiwan,
you know, wants to talk to Li,
why should I talk to her?"
So basically Taiwan is to China
like, I don't know, California
or some chunk of the U.S. is
to the U.S. They believe this
is inherently China, Chinese.
This is our territory.
But it's an errant
province for the time being.
Well, we're taking it back.
So that's [inaudible] the Taiwanese
they have 25 million people living
in Taiwan in a very
successful economy
that functions as a
democratic system--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison:
Where people are free.
So as the Chinese mainland gets more
and more authoritarian, and more
and more stricter on what people can
do, people in Taiwan thinking less
and less this is a good idea for
me to be part of this mainland.
So the tension between China
and Taiwan is likely to increase
as the mainland becomes more
constraining and more authoritarian.
And the Taiwanese appreciate
their democracy more.
>> David M. Rubenstein: All right.
A fourth potential source of
confrontation between China
and the United States you point
out is the Senkaku Islands,
which are these islands off
of Japan that some people
in Japan claim are theirs, some
people in China claim are theirs.
There's nobody living there.
Why are these barren islands going
to cause a potential problem?
>> Graham Allison: Well, again,
this is just part of the,
think of the rising
power that's looking
out like Teddy Roosevelt was
looking out at the Caribbean saying,
"What are the Spanish
doing here in Cuba?"
So it's just kind of in their face.
Now there's a set of islands,
as you mentioned, the Senkakus,
that the Chinese call the Diaoyus,
which the U.S. actually doesn't
agree in history they belong
to Japan part of the time,
to China part of the time,
depending on the relative
strength of the two parties.
They went back and forth.
The U.S. agrees about
the ultimate resolution
of the ownership we do
not take a position.
But we happened to give
back these islands,
which we owned after the war.
We took it after World War II
when we gave back Okinawa
to Japan currently.
And the U.S. government has said
to China three or four times,
"If you attack the Senkaku
Islands, we will defend Japan."
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
All right.
So these are potential
sources of confrontation.
But right now is somebody in
the U.S. working on a strategy
that might keep us from going to a
military confrontation with China?
And is somebody in China working
on a confrontation strategy
that might avoid a confrontation?
>> Graham Allison:
Well, we would hope so.
Okay?
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Do you have anybody
in mind you think is
working on it or?
>> Graham Allison: Well, I think
on the Chinese side
they've been fascinated
by Thucydidian trap
hypothesis and the history.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Do they agree with you?
When you go to China you
talk to Chinese leaders.
Are they thinking you're
wrong in your analysis
that there's a potential
confrontation going?
>> Graham Allison: Well, Xi
Jinping holds two positions
which are contradictory.
On the one hand he wants to say,
"There's no such thing
as Thucydides's trap."
By which he means this
is not inevitable.
And on the other hand we
must make a maximum effort
to escape Thucydides's trap.
And he's got a lot of people working
on the question, "What do we have
to do to avoid [inaudible]?"
>> David M. Rubenstein: When you
go over there and you talk to him
about this, they say your analysis
is wrong, or you're an American
and you just don't know
what you're talking about.
What are they mostly saying to you?
>> Graham Allison: After
they get over the proposition
that it's not inevitable, and I say,
"Thucydides didn't mean
really inevitable."
And I don't say inevitable.
Four out of 16 is not inevitable.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison: It's
just odds are not good.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison: It's a real
serious structural stress.
Then they say, "Well,
okay, if we were trying
to avoid Thucydides's trap, or
escape, what do we have to do?"
And I go through my suggestions,
[inaudible] you would
wish [inaudible] would be
that the two governments, Xi
and Trump, would appoint two
or three people each who they
trusted, and say, "You folks sit
down and be imaginative, not just
within the box, very imaginative.
And ask first how are
the ways that parties
like Kim Jong-un could drag
us into a war we don't want?
Let's be clear.
How could this happen, and what
do we have to do to prevent that?"
So that part would be pretty easy.
Then, secondly, how do we adapt
and adjust in this relationship,
which is going to be painful, in
which we're going to each have
to do things different
than we have been--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison: Doing before?
And in that what you would
like is to distinguish
between vital national
interests for each party,
and things that are just vested.
So some of the things that the
U.S. is doing we've been doing
for 70 years.
But we don't have to
be doing forever.
I would say it's now my personal
view the U.S. interests in who owns
which island in the South
China Sea is pretty limited.
I would like to see us
fight over who the Paracels
or the Scarborough
Shoals, or some island
that the Chinese built
in the South China Sea.
Well, then do you mean you would be
willing to compromise in some way?
I would say in the Cold War we
compromised in a lot of ways.
The captive nations of
Eastern Europe stayed captive
for four decades.
We didn't go fight to liberate them.
We dealt with this over
a longer period of time.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So today
as you look at Thucydides's trap
in the history, and you look
at the Chinese leadership,
you look at the American
leadership, how likely in your view
over the next five, ten or 15
or 20 years do you think it is
that the United States
and China will be unable
to avoid this Thucydides's trap?
>> Graham Allison: That's
an extremely good question.
That's a hard question.
In the book I argue I do believe
that history as usual, I'm sorry,
[inaudible], business as usual.
If we just do business
as usual in the U.S.
/Chinese relations we'll
get history as usual.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: And history
as usual is pretty catastrophic.
But, as I argue in the book
also, as Santiana taught us,
only if we refuse to study history
are we condemned to repeat it.
So, now, can I imagine the U.S.
government being as imaginative
as people were in inventing
the Cold War strategy?
I can. I mean we already
did this once.
Could I imagine China being
inventive, especially since,
as you say, they've
got a long horizon?
So they prepared to take issues
and put them on the shelf
for a long period of time.
But I would say if the performance
for the next 20 years was,
if it's no different than the
performance in the last 20 years,
then I would say the likelihood
of conflict is significant,
maybe 40%, yeah.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
But conflict--
>> Graham Allison: War.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Non-nuclear--
>> Graham Allison: War.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Non-nuclear [inaudible].
>> Graham Allison: Well,
I hope non-nuclear.
But part of the reason why
in the Cold War the U.S.
and the Soviet Union, which
became to be so cautious
about having a non-nuclear war
where we're killing each other,
is that it's not clear
why it doesn't escalate.
And, as I point out in the
book, now that you have cyber
as another lubricant, as well as
the normal ways in which you can,
once you have a war
going the question is,
"Why should I lose at this level--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Graham Allison: Rather
than move up just a level?"
And Putin has already
introduced into the conversation,
and the Chinese have been
looking at this very carefully,
the notion that, well,
but if I'm losing
at the conventional level I can
just use a tactical nuclear weapon,
just a limited use
of a nuclear weapon.
And while you and I
would say, "Yikes!
That sounds crazy."
That was actually what we
thought of doing in the Cold War
when we thought we had
only a few divisions,
and the Soviet Union
had a lot of divisions.
So I would say stay out
of a conventional war,
because don't have any
comfort or confidence
that it wouldn't escalate
to something much worse.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Now
in your book we just talked
about North Korea, and it's
been in the news a lot lately,
so it's not quite in your book, but
your own assessment as a scholar
in this area and somebody
who studied this area, China,
North Korea, United States,
why is it that the Chinese can't
have more influence on North Korea,
and get Kim Jong-un
to seem more rational?
What's the reason?
>> Graham Allison:
That's a great question.
And I think he hasn't been,
he and they haven't been
sufficiently motivated to do so.
China controls the oil
lifeline to North Korea.
Ninety percent of all oil that
fuels the trucks and the planes
for the military, as well as the
cars for the leadership when they go
to their country houses on
the weekend, comes from China.
So if it squeezed that lifeline,
it could have a huge
impact on North Korea.
But,--
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Why can't they do it?
>> Graham Allison: Well, put
it in a, if you put it back
into the Thucydides in context,
the Chinese when they look
at this situation, as one said
to me, "Look, there's no problem
in the Korean Peninsula that
wouldn't be solved if you left.
The problem is you're there."
I mean if the U.S. were not
on the Korean Peninsula,
you would have a unified Korea.
It would be a tributary
state of China.
They would allow it to
have nuclear weapons.
So this is, and I said to
them, "Well, wait a minute.
I can understand why
you might think that.
But let me tell you about my
history, how we got there.
We didn't volunteer to come there.
We came there because
your ally attacked them."
The story I told before.
So the North Korean as a
situation is extremely dangerous,
because it's an overlay on
this fundamental dynamic.
And I think from Xi's
point of view, if you look,
he saw they're almost working
as hard to sanction South Korea
for its deployment of
THAAD, of missile defenses.
So look and see what's happening
to Hyundai or Samsung in China,
or what's happening to
Chinese visits to South Korea.
So they see this in terms of
a much more complex dynamic.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Now we avoided a Hot War
with the Soviet Union
you pointed out,
because a containment approach
was put together by many people,
the wise men, as they
were called, Robert Kenan
and Robert Lovett, among others.
Who are the wise men in the U.S.
government today that are going
to put together this strategy
that's going to be so helpful?
And wise women, too.
>> Graham Allison:
And women, yes, yes.
So two people in the
current administration
who were both serious students of
Thucydides, and who have looked
at the book, and thought
about it are H.R. McMaster,
who's Trump's National
Security Adviser.
H.R. can quote more
Thucydides than anybody.
He used to teach this at
Stanford, you know, College.
And Jim Mattis was
a serious historian.
And Thucydides is part
of his mental library.
So they can understand
Thucydides's trap risks
with all the else going on.
They're going to have a day, and
people whom they would engage,
an exercise like what happened.
In the conventions of the Cold
War strategy, I don't know.
We should remember
in the Cold War case,
I mean the Cold War strategy
was unbelievably imaginative.
And it didn't just pop out
of anybody's head one day.
Kennan wrote back his famous
telegram in the spring of 1946,
just a year after World War II,
saying the Soviet Union is going
to be a bigger threat
than the Nazis were.
It wasn't for four more years, as
people invented the Marshall Plan
and NATO and the IMF and the World
Bank, and all the other elements
of the Cold War strategy,
that the thing was in place.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Now
I said earlier Robert Lovett
and Robert Kennan.
It should be George Kennan.
But--
>> Graham Allison: George Kennan.
>> David M. Rubenstein: In
the two minutes we have left,
I would like you to
do this in two minutes
in a slightly different context.
You are the leading expert, academic
expert on the Cuban Missile Crisis.
So what happened there that
avoided a confrontation?
What was the brilliance of
President Kennedy or his advisors?
How did we avoid it, in that case,
going to a nuclear confrontation?
And what lesson would you
take away that you would give
to the current administration
they should take
from the Cuban Missile
Crisis in two minutes?
>> Graham Allison: Okay.
So the Cuban Missile
Crisis, for those of you
who missed it, was in 1962.
Okay? And it's the most dangerous
moment in recorded history.
So the U.S. discovered
the Soviet Union trying
to place nuclear-tipped
missiles in Cuba.
Kennedy determined this
is not going to stand.
We're not going to
allow this to happen.
And actually took a
course of action,
which he thought had a
one-in-three chance of nuclear war,
to prevent the Soviet Union from
having nuclear-tipped missiles
in Cuba, even though they already
had nuclear-tipped missiles
in the Soviet Union
that could kill us.
So that's a long complicated story.
In any case, we started
it with a blockade.
So no more shipments to Cuba.
And then by the end of the second
week, all this was condensed
in 13 days, Kennedy gave to the
Soviet Union a very strange cocktail
to Khrushchev, communicated
to him privately.
First, a public demand.
The missiles have to be withdrawn.
Secondly, a private ultimatum
that if this doesn't happen in 24
or 48 hours, I'm going
to attack these missiles.
And, thirdly, a secret
sweetener that said the missiles
that we have deployed in Turkey,
that you're so concerned about,
I'm not going to have
any quid pro quo.
But I'm telling you if we resolve
the Cuban issue in six months,
those missiles will be gone.
So Kennedy drew from this,
what he thought was the big takeaway
going forward, that when you get it
to basically eyeball-to-eyeball,
don't give your adversary a choice
between humiliation and war.
Find some other--
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
>> Graham Allison: Option.
And I would hope that in this
current situation, as we look at it,
we would end up finding
something equally imaginative.
>> David M. Rubenstein: All right.
Well, I hope so as well.
And I highly recommend this book
"Destined for War," Graham Allison.
If all of you want to know more
about Thucydides's
trap, please read it.
And, Graham, thank you for
a great work [inaudible].
>> Graham Allison: Thank you.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.